well any any genetic disorder is an
interaction with the environment so I
don't exclude environment I just don't
see yet any strong evidence for a
particular environmental factor I think
that one could do studies for example
one could go to third world countries
and do a study and ask is the rate of
autism they are the same as it is in the
developed countries no one has done a
study that I know of of that type but it
certainly could be done that would
answer that question but certainly
anything having to do with with the
development of an organism has an
environmental component to it but you
can only study that when there's when
there's some evidence which enables you
to isolate that environmental component
I think the vaccine studies have been
now largely discredited
they took mercury out of the vaccine and
this rates of autism didn't change and
now of the 12 all authors of the
original paper they've got some people
very excited I think 11 of those 12
authors have now withdrawn their backing
for that paper and the the methods used
in that paper are really in doubt so I I
don't take it as any as there being any
evidence that vaccines is such an
environmental factor it's unfortunate
that the age at which parents begin to
recognize autism and their children
often correlates with the age at which
they receive vaccinations that's the
unfortunate thing there is a portion of
the autism probably the majority of
autism where you can detect it very
early once then the child is almost
that's almost after the child is born
many parents of autistic children say
that they could tell very early on that
there's something wrong with your child
there are about a quarter of the cases
of autism where it looks like the child
in the parents opinion has been
developing normally and then
to their mind suddenly goes off course
and I think at least 5% of cases it's
it's been very well documented that
actually a child has begun to lose gains
that they have made so there is this
component that's very tragic when parent
feels relieved that they've gotten
through and I think every parent who has
a child suffers through nightmares that
you know hoping that their child will be
healthy and they give birth to a healthy
child and then you know at age 2 or 3
the child suddenly stops developing
that's tragedy of horrendous proportions
and it's natural for the parents of such
children to look around for the possible
causes something external however should
be borne in mind that our brains
continuously are developing at that age
and it is well known that there are
genetic defects whose onsets can occur
at almost any particular age for example
there are class of disorders that are
called storage disorders where the child
develops normally but because of the
build up of some compound due to the
faulty metabolism of some essential
thing that they eat every day builds up
to a point and then begins to poison the
brain and these in these cases a child
will develop normally up to a certain
age and then will often regress and
sometimes will died so the idea that you
know you can't have sudden onset of an
illness when the child's 2 or 3 is is
just as wrong if there were you know
clear environmental signal for example
sonograms or too much television or
vaccinations you know that would be
something that one could study but in
the absence of evidence for that you
have to ask yourself well what should we
be looking for should it be the plastic
and bomb
and I don't think we can do that in our
culture I don't think we can look for
these possible environmental insults
they're just far too many but if you go
to a place you know like Nepal or
Mongolia or some places whose
environment is completely different they
don't have television they still have
grandmothers raising the children they
don't get sonograms you could begin to
tease out and do you know what
epidemiologists do they go and do
cultural comparisons so for example
cultural comparisons have told us the
incidence of breast cancer in Japan is
1/3 the rate of the incidence of breast
cancer in America and when Japanese
women grow up in America their rate of
breast cancer is the same as American
women okay you can say the environment
possibly including culture in some way
because of the rate the age of which you
undergo puberty is is relevant to breast
cancer has a study like that been done
for autism no that's where you would
start and none of that's been done as
far as I know